The Joe Rogan experience.
Because in LA there's the here being famous,
doesn't seem like a viable option in LA. It seemed like the most viable option,
like the most primary option.
Oh, you mean like there's a.
There's a community of people that are focused around
the Kardashians and the, the, the, you know,
the athletes and the musicians and the, this and the, that,
and their whole ideas. And, you know, this obviously is, sounds hypocritical.
It was coming from someone who happens to be famous. But I think that it's,
it's a empty pursuit. It's, you know, you can,
you can get famous doing a thing that you love, or you can try to be famous.
And there are two very different things.
And I think there's been many times in my life where I was trying to get famous.
Cause it seemed like it was impossible, right.
Like when I was young and first getting on television first doing comedy,
because it just seemed like impossible. Like how does someone get famous?
How does it, I could see other people famous. Like, how are they famous?
This is great. It seemed nuts. Yeah. But be careful what you wish for.
Uh, you think fame changed you? Like,
are you able to like be cognizant of
ways in which the fact that this podcast is the biggest podcast in the
world and just all, all of that, how that's changing your mind. I mean, that,
I think about that with power that you might not be cognizant of
the way that power is changing you. That's why I find Putin fascinating.
So what.
Like, do you look in a mirror and see, like,
you're not the man you used to be in some dimension,
like this is a different human, because you're so famous.
Uh, believe it or not. I think about that very little.
And I think I see.
My success. I think.
So. I see that legitimately. I don't think.
I think just interacting with you offline in general. I don't think
it doesn't look at you acknowledge to yourself that you're famous. Like you,
you don't, you're not living with that truth. You're not like lingering it.
You're still pursuing the things that make you happy that yeah. I,
I, I, I tend to believe that you could do the same with power.
Like I tend to believe a president could do that same kind of thing.
That's what we would hope. Right?
You would hope that some president gets to a position of power.
Not because they crave it,
but because they have solutions to problems and they genuinely think that they
can help the world. Now, I'm not saying that I'm not equating my, like I'm not,
um, uh,
favorably comparing myself to a president or something like that. But I,
um, I think
I got a slow drip of fame and that's one of the things that helped
me. You know, I started,
I got on television for the first time in like the early nineties with
doing stand up comedy.
And then it led to a sitcom that led to fear factor in the UFC and all these
different things.
And then ultimately it accidentally led to the biggest thing that I ever did,
which was, this was, this is the biggest thing you ever did this,
this is oh, by far. Yeah. By, by magnitudes.
But yeah,
massive giant numbers of magnitudes,
different than anything I've ever done.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the Jerry on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan expanse.